oh ne mangez-vous pas les
séquences de tournage de la famille bleue séquences de campagne d'absentéisme scolaire que
vous vous présentez aux élections Je fais
vraiment partie du problème Michael est
enfin de retour ensemble oh super prenez vos
affaires sortons d'ici
bien ça n'a pas duré longtemps  peut-être mais
peut-être que nous pouvons comprendre où tout
s'est mal passé J'ai fait une énorme erreur il
semble que beaucoup de choses ont changé au fil des ans Je
viens de me faire exploser pour la première fois en
cinq ans enfin pas tout
ce qui a réuni tout le monde
en ville cette fois mais ce nouveau
départ est différent je n'aime pas ça
parce que les Bluths reçoivent enfin
le prix qu'ils pensent mériter pourraient
nous donner que nous nous le donnons
bien il ne semblait toujours pas
qu'il obtiendrait  les votes parce que rien ne
vous retient comme la famille salut je suis venu
ici pour sauver tout le monde Oh
regarde qui est de retour je pensais que nous étions
censés aller à la chaise Arrested
Development saison cinq au revoir uniquement sur
Netflix